the National Rifle Association has filed
a lawsuit to try to block a Florida
School Safety bill that puts new
restrictions on guns final passage of
the measure came after a gunman killed
17 people at a high school with a
semi-automatic assault style rifle last
month Florida's governor says the bill
balances individual rights with the need
for Public Safety Adriana Diaz reports
with the sweep of a pen Florida Governor
Rick Scott is allowing some teachers to
carry guns in classrooms while also
tightening access to firearms the new
law also limits rifle sales to people 21
or over after a three day waiting period
allows law enforcement to confiscate
firearms from people who make threats
and allocates four hundred million
dollars for school safety and mental
health but what it doesn't do is ban
assault rifles the one thing that the
students had a consensus on is that they
wanted an assault weapons ban this bill
doesn't this law doesn't include that
rather than banning specific weapons we
need to ban specific people from having
any weapon by allowing some school staff
to carry weapons in counties that opt
into the program Florida joins at least
11 other states with similar measures
but teachers in Florida's Union
including Felicia Alvarez and Shane cook
want guns out of schools
these students are our future right now
we are showing them that the answer to
violence is more violence the idea of
being armed is very enticing but the
bigger issue is that we're creating laws
that are not fixing the problem the
families of all 17 victims in the
Parkland shootings support the new law
some like tonymont Aalto who lost his
daughter Gina were there for the signing
we have paid a terrible price for this
progress we call on more states to
follow Florida's lead and create
meaningful legislation to make all
schools safer this time must be
different gun control laws have emerged
from other school shootings but what's
significant about this state is that
Florida is such a gun friendly state it
also has a republic
governor and republican-controlled
legislature now governor Scott is a
member of the NRA
he received an A+ rating from the NRA
but he broke from the NRA with this move
earlier this week an NRA lobbyist said
that the legislation was a display of
quote bullying and coercion for CBS this
morning Saturday Adriana Diaz
Tallahassee